so we're smiling looking out at the
clouds this morning in the wind thinking
oh it sure would be nice if we could get
some more rain there are thunderstorms
that have been down in southern clark
county boy they've blown up a lot of
wind through our area 50 mile an hour
winds in north las vegas or north
henderson excuse me this was in the 4
a.m hour so it's been a while since
we've had the strong winds but you can
see the trees blowing a legion stadium
had a 46 mile an hour wind gusts same
for harry reid and north las vegas 40
mile an hour winds so we've had some
strong winds these are outflow winds
from the line of showers and
thunderstorms in southern clark county
80s and a couple of areas with still
around 90 degrees we're warm we're muggy
we've got dew points just right around
60 degrees with
that's telling us there's just a lot of
moisture around 83 in laughlin had about
a quarter of an inch of rain in laughlin
rain around searchlight cal nevery and
overdose state line 80's pahrump and
indian springs low 90's in
in mesquite this morning right now so
here's that line of showers and
thunderstorms it was packed with
lightning and some pretty good heavy
rain but as it's been traveling north
you can see that it's weakening quite a
bit i don't want to say it's completely
fizzling out because it's still holding
together somewhat and it still has some
lightning with it as it travels
especially up around us 95 and we still
are looking for at least some light rain
from this and the danger of lightning
with it with some gusty winds this all
came up from a complex out of sonora
mexico last night high pressure will
still keep the monsoon moisture
circulating so even after this line of
showers moves through this morning we'll
take a little break later in the morning
and then another chance of thunderstorms
through the afternoon with daytime
heating we'll look for a high of about
105 today after that high pressure kind
of moves closer to us caps off the
monsoon moisture and we're looking at
heat for the rest of the week back up to
108 109 and then maybe some more monsoon
thunderstorms sunday monday